voted to procedural legislation before
us in order in order to preserve maximum
flexibility for a productive
conversation to continue between the
White House and our Democratic
colleagues we are willing to continue
discussions on those proposals with the
leader the president the Speaker of the
House and the leader of the house so
you're saying there's a chance
the partial government shutdown which is
less than six hours away five hours 20
minutes away
would possibly be avoided if they
continue negotiating and they come with
some solution that would then have to
pass the Senate and then bounce back to
the house get past there and head to the
President's desk why do we call it a
partial government shutdown because a
lot of the spending bills have already
been passed if you look at this pie
chart 75% have already been funded we're
talking about 25 percent here not yet
enacted it's still a lot of people
potentially that wouldn't get paid for
some period of time depending on how
long it goes as we talked about it
yesterday they got their checks this
week there's a holiday coming up so
there's some buffer room there but it's
still very serious let's bring in our
panel start there Tom Rogan commentary
writer for the Washington Examiner Molly
Hemingway senior editor at The
Federalist and David Cantonese senior
politics writer for US News and World
Report okay David so you know it they
left this vote open today because the
Republicans didn't have the votes and
then they make a deal and now they're
talking and we just don't know where
that's gonna go something's gonna have
to give if they can get this done in
four hours either they can maneuver the
language so it's for border security but
maybe not for exactly a wall maybe they
throw a little money and then Trump can
claim victory but look I think the
Democrats hold the cards here I thought
it was very telling that earlier in the
day when the Vice President went up
there with Jared Kushner and Mick
Mulvaney that the meeting was with
Schumer it is not with McConnell it's
about getting Democrats on board and I
saw in the last procedural vote Doug
Jones the senator from Alabama voted to
move forward so maybe there's some
opportunity to get Democratic
but tough to get to 60 joe manchin voted
against it from West Virginia Molly this
is what Chuck Schumer kept on referring
to today numerous times talking to
reporters this is the Oval Office
meeting back on December 11th
you know what I'll say yes if we don't
get what we want one way or the other
whether it's through you through a
military through anything you want to
call I will shut down the gun
I'm proud to shut down the government
for border security Chuck because the
people of this country don't want
criminals and people that have lots of
problems and drugs pouring into our
country so I will take the mantle I will
be the one to shut it down I'm not gonna
blame you for it the last time you shut
it down it didn't work I will take the
medal of shutting down and I'm gonna
shut it down for border but we believe
you so fast-forward 10 days and this is
the Trump today the Democrats president
today the Democrats now own the shutdown
saying the bill had passed the house and
was now in the Senate and what I think
is really interesting is we have not
solved a lot of our immigration problems
because the incentive structure hasn't
been there both Democrats and
Republicans have benefited by being able
to use the issue without actually
solving it what makes this very
interesting is Donald Trump has no
incentive to do anything other than wait
for a bill that provides money for the
border fence and he can wait as long as
he wants partly because it's we've got a
government at 75% funded but also
because if he does not provide this it
is a very serious problem for him and
his electoral future and he has no
incentive to accept anything other than
meaningful border wall funding and so I
think when he looks at the shutdown he
views it as something where he gets to
take credit for caring enough about
border security to go to this point but
Democrats actually like they might just
be playing into his hands by going into
it if they don't if they're not willing
to play and they've already voted for
border security they've already voted
for border fences there should not be
anything that well and that's symbolic
and that's where the opposition is
that's where I think the horse trading
has to
her were security that's not a wall I
mean the president even changed the
language on this he's talking about
slaps weeded out this picture of what
the potential new wall would look like
steel slap barrier Tom yes I think David
is corrected if we get to a shutdown
there will be fudging of language some
money but to Molly's point I think that
is the critical component here I think
president Trump to a degree wants the
shutdown because he feels especially in
the context of the Matis the negative
coverage there he wants to show actually
I'm the hard-charging I'm the candidate
Trump and that will matter going into
that presidential election year because
whether you know it or not or whether we
know it or not a lot of America's did
vote for him then I also think the
president's benefit is that Democrat has
being seen to oppose border security
from a hard left line by a lot of
American perception will be negative for
their candidate so this may flip in his
favor later on yeah will monitor is
throughout the night you'll see all the
developments here on Fox News Channel
you mentioned secretary matters stepping
down resignation letter yesterday that
was you know frankly there were a lot of
things in that letter if you read it
again again again he does not say
anything positive about President Trump
and he's very pointed about leaving
because of ideological differences and
specifically about Syrian troop
withdrawals and then Afghanistan troop
withdrawals Molly and I think one of the
things that was interesting that came
out about this was that we learned eight
months ago Donald Trump gave mattis six
months to get out of Syria and not only
did he not come up with a plan to get
out of Syria it seems like he took that
time as an opportunity to ramp up
efforts in Syria
it is fine that general mattis has
different foreign policy views than
president Trump but the American people
elected president Trump to be the
commander in chief and he has every
right to have very good defense
secretary and other people who actually
understand that they need to provide him
with good options and so if he never had
any intention of upholding these
policies he probably shouldn't have
taken the job we should have resigned at
the point when he realized that there
was a conflict however the critics would
say David that how it happened the
process of you know the story leaking
that this was starting to happen and
then the president tweeting it out and
the allies and the lawmakers and the
oversight and the Pentagon we're
really in the dark yes and I think you
know the story that has been told is
that Madison went over there one last
time to try to change the president's
mind on Syria but then had the his
resignation letter written submit it I
mean we were talking in the green room
before though I mean who gets better
press in Washington and general mattis
the guy I mean his getting accolades
from Democrats from from liberals so I
think there is some of this piling on
and by the way some of them said that
they were really opposed to having
troops on the ground in Syria for sure
now they are suddenly really behind that
because it's an anti-trump thing so I
think there is something that I would
just say the broader question though who
replaces mattis is gonna be a huge
question in 2019 the president gonna
have four cabinet confirmation hearings
you and ambassador defense attorney
general and interior oh all coming in
2019 and let's he'll probably also have
Muller yeah to deal with the beginning
of 2019 I do think interestingly though
from the sort of looking at the
president's foreign policy he has
obviously the right to have the defense
secretary he wants you know whatever we
think about the Syria decision I don't
necessarily buy into this argument
though that Madison's departure means
the real America first because if you
actually look at the cabinet balance
Bolton Pompeo very tough on Iran the
idea of Tom cotton being talked about as
the next secretary very tough on Iran
mattis even though the Obama
administration pushed him out for being
too hawkish on Iran we've seen as the
interlocutor
sort of so we'll see we